23 de junio del año 2016 una fecha que
pasará a la historia ese día el 51,9% de
los británicos votaron por abandonar la
Unión Europea el divorcio se había
consumado el brexit sería realidad que
por supuesto es lo que pasó pero os
acordáis de Cuáles fueron las
principales promesas de la campaña
progresid pues hubo muchas pero esta fue
con diferencia una de las más
importantes y de las más decisivas
Michael one
is my
graceble el brexit es la única forma de
controlar la inmigración afirman los
activistas de hecho tal y como podéis
ver las encuestas anteriores al
referéndum mostraran claramente que la
inmensa mayoría de los británicos fueran
o no partidarios del brexit consideraban
que permitiría que el gobierno británico
pudiera volver a controlar las fronteras
y reducir así la enorme cantidad de
inmigrantes que estaban entrando en el
país el brexit suponía muchas cosas pero
electoralmente hablando pasaba sobre
todo por la inmigración y los efectos
que está provocaba en el sistema de
salud en los Colegios en el mercado de
trabajo y en general en la vida diaria
de los británicos Pues bien desde
entonces han pasado Ni más ni menos que
siete largos años exactamente la misma
vida que he visto el político porque
sacamos el canal el mismo año del brexit
y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
que ha supuesto exactamente el brexit
para la inmigración se ha cumplido
realmente esta promesa Pues mis queridos
amigos de visualpolitik los datos
parecen decir algo muy diferente la
inmigración del Reino Unido casi se
triplica a pesar de las promesas del
brexit los cruces de inmigrantes por el
Canal de la Mancha alcanzan un nuevo
récord diario en 2023 el debate sobre la
inmigración se ha convertido en uno de
los temas centrales en el número 10 de
downing Street
y todo esto Pese a que ahora el Reino
Unido puede manejar de nuevo sus
fronteras da igual la llegada de
inmigrantes no solo no se ha reducido
sino que se ha incrementado y todo esto
a pesar de que la situación económica de
Reino Unido no es particularmente buena
Así que la pregunta que podemos hacernos
ahora es hasta qué punto el Reino Unido
se ha convertido en un país abierto la
inmigración Qué ha pasado con la que fue
una de las grandes promesas del brexit Y
sabías que el equipo de sunat espera
hacer de la inmigración O mejor dicho de
la lucha contra la inmigración su gran
apuesta política de Cara a las próximas
elecciones del año 2025 Por cierto
hablando de Reino Unido sabíais que su
economía no está atravesando por sus
mejores momentos por ejemplo las
estimaciones nos dicen que los salarios
reales de Reino Unido son hoy más bajos
que hace 15 años al tiempo que la
inflación ha batido su peor registro en
las últimas cuatro décadas el brexit la
falta de inversión y muchos problemas
regulatorios han creado una situación de
extrema debilidad desde el año 2007 la
producción por hora de esta economía
Apenas ha crecido un 0,7% anual el
segundo peor registro del g7 tan solo
por detrás de Italia la pregunta Es que
le está pasando a la economía británica
Cómo puede el Reino Unido escapar de
esta situación Pues bien de todo esto y
de mucho más es de lo que se habla en el
próximo vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido
que como sabéis es el canal de
información financiera de mutuoactivos
con el que colaboramos es muy
esclarecedor os dejo el link en la
descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
abran las puertas
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik es
imposible hablar del Reino Unido post
brexit sin mencionar a Alexander Boris
de pepple Johnson vamos el Boris Johnson
de toda la vida hablamos del mismo tipo
que era capaz de ofrecer té a los
periodistas por la mañana pegarse con un
paraguas al mediodía y aplacar a niños
durante partidos de rugby por las tardes
en resumidas cuentas uno de los
personajes más pintorescos y más
controvertidos de la política moderna un
político que fue uno de los grandes
Defensores y de los grandes promotores
del brexit de hecho fue probablemente el
líder conservador más importante a la
hora de defender esta postura es decir
la del leaf Y sí entre las razones
Johnson también hablaba de la
inmigración y del control de las
fronteras atentos
pero no solo eso Boris Johnson insistía
una y otra vez en que seguir formando
parte de la Unión Europea supondría
renunciar a tener cualquier control
sobre la frontera es profundamente
corrosivo para la confianza Popular en
la democracia que cada año los políticos
del Reino Unido llegan al público que
pueden reducir la inmigración a decenas
de miles y luego descubren que no logran
sus objetivos por cientos de miles ojo
esto no quiere decir que Boris Johnson
fuera un líder antimigración ni nada por
el estilo simplemente decía no estar de
acuerdo con la llegada descontrolada de
cientos y cientos de miles de personas
cada año pero al mismo tiempo también
decía cosas como esta Boris Johnson dice
que la baja inmigración podría conducir
al estancamiento económico sea como sea
En aquel momento Boris Johnson era
simplemente el alcalde de Londres y
aunque ya se veía claramente que su
objetivo era llegar al 10 de Downey
Street tuvo que esperar porque tras la
dimisión de David Cameron que había
hecho campaña por mantenerse dentro de
la Unión Europea pese a ser conservador
se hizo con el timón de Mando suministra
de exteriores que era Teresa
[Música]
Mi fracaso estrepitosamente a la hora de
gestionar las negociaciones para
completar el brexit su dimisión le dio
el liderazgo del gobierno a Boris
Johnson en julio de 2019 entonces una de
las primeras cosas que hizo el nuevo
Primer Ministro británico fue comenzar a
trabajar Precisamente en el tema
migratorio de esta forma en marzo de
2021 su gobierno presentó un nuevo plan
para la política de inmigración un plan
que finalmente de vino en un proyecto de
ley presentado a la cámara de los
comunes a finales de junio de ese mismo
2021 y aprobada en abril de 2022
desde hace ya casi una década la
política británica vive prácticamente
obsesionada con este tema ahora bien si
tenemos en cuenta la llegada de
extranjeros Durante la etapa de Paris
Johnson las cosas no cambiaron demasiado
excepto porque la inmigración Se dispara
aún más por ejemplo podemos echar un
vistazo a lo ocurrido con los refugiados
tal y como podéis ver en 2019 las
autoridades británicas aprobaron un 70%
más de solicitudes y tras la pandemia
los números crecieron aún más y esto es
tan solo un ejemplo porque lo cierto Es
que las visas de trabajo también se
dispararon desde que Boris Johnson llegó
al gobierno en 2022 se otorgaron casi un
70% más que en el año 2016 que era el
año del referéndum y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando todos en este momento
pero qué demonios pasó no se suponía que
el brexit defendía limitar la
inmigración no era caso Boris Johnson un
firme partidario de controlar las
fronteras de repente en Reino Unido se
han vuelto todos súper amigables con los
inmigrantes refugis Welcome puertas
abiertas para todos
[Música]
cambio de juego
el Reino Unido tal y como ocurre con el
resto de Europa tiene una enorme
necesidad de mano de obra joven tiene
porque su población cada vez está más
envejecida pero es que también porque
las empresas necesitan perfiles muy
diferentes desde aquellos orientados a
trabajos poco cualificados y de muy poco
valor añadido que los británicos ya no
quieren hacer hasta aquellos perfiles
que son muy especializados y que también
Son imprescindibles para las Industrias
más punteras por ejemplo para la
industria tecnológica o para la
importantísima industria financiera
británica ya sabéis la industria
financiera que está en la City de
Londres de la que hemos hablado millones
de veces en visualpolitik necesitas mano
de obra especializada Así que Johnson
llegó al 10 de Downey Street con esta
contradicción entre manos porque por un
lado se suponía que tenía que cumplir
con las promesas del brexit y sacar
adelante una reforma que ordenara y
redujera la llegada de extranjeros pero
es que por el otro lado tenía que ser
una reforma que no supusieron obstáculo
para la economía nacional y la pregunta
es qué pensáis que ocurrió pues ya lo
hemos visto los datos no nos generan
ninguna duda
y sabéis que es lo más curioso de todo
pues que todo esto no
erosionó particularmente la
particularidad de Boris Johnson de
repente lo que era un tema tan
absolutamente importante incluso para
determinar la salida de la Unión Europea
se convirtió en algo más o menos
intrascendente de hecho según un estudio
elaborado por el instituto de política
del Kings College de Londres desde el
brexit el rechazo de los británicos
hacia los trabajadores extranjeros se ha
derrumbado una tendencia diferente a lo
que está ocurriendo en otros países como
Australia o Canadá no me diréis que no
es una paradoja o sea los británicos
parecen estar volviéndose mucho más
abiertos y receptivos inmediatamente
después de abandonar la Unión Europea
Pese a que el principal motivo electoral
de los progressive fue precisamente
echar el cierre y reducir drásticamente
la llegada de extranjeros que es
exactamente lo contrario lo que está
sucediendo y aún más ni esto a
erosionado particularmente al gobierno
ni tampoco los británicos parecen
molestos y ojo porque el rechazo a los
inmigrantes se ha desplomado entre todos
los grupos de edad es decir que no
importa si hablamos de la generación Z
de los millennials de los baby boomers o
de la generación para guerra Es más este
último grupo o sea la generación de los
nacidos antes de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial el rechazo se ha desplomado a
menos de la mitad de los últimos años
hasta apenas el 8% y la pregunta que os
estaréis haciendo ahora es por qué pues
probablemente sea por esto
la economía británica no está
atravesando su mejor momento pero aún
así la tasa de desempleo es muy baja y
hay muchas profesiones con una enorme
carencia de profesionales eso explica
por ejemplo por qué según una reciente
encuesta de ipsos los británicos están
como locos porque llegan al país más
médicos más profesionales de enfermería
e incluso más agricultores de hecho
menos del 20% de los británicos quieren
ahora que se reduzca la llegada de
profesionales de prácticamente cualquier
actividad curiosamente la única
excepción son los banqueros
[Música]
pero está claro que esa fobia tiene
mucho más que ver con los bancos que con
los trabajadores de bancos y eso no es
todo ese mismo estudio de ipsos muestra
que el 46% de los británicos valora
positivamente el impacto de la
inmigración frente al 29% que lo valora
negativamente una percepción negativa
que curiosamente no ha dejado de
reducirse desde precisamente el año 2016
es decir que ahora que llegan muchos más
inmigrantes los británicos ya no están
preocupados Claro que una cosa son los
británicos y otra los políticos porque
el actual gobierno conservador Está
sacando adelante una reforma de la ley
migratoria tan polémica que incluso está
detrás el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos y diréis seré de qué estamos
hablando Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
jugando con fuego
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
puede que los británicos ya no les
importe mucho el tema este de la
inmigración Pero en cambio los políticos
Oye que siguen r en abril de 2022 el
gobierno de Johnson logró que se
aprobara su nuevo plan de inmigración
por ejemplo esta nueva ley introdujo un
sistema de dos niveles que ofrecía los
refugiados diferentes niveles de
protección dependiendo de cómo
ingresarán al Reino Unido a los que
ingresaban por ruta seguras ilegales se
les concede permiso para quedarse Sin
condiciones pero aquellos que ingresen
de forma irregular solo podrían aspirar
a una Estancia temporal de 30 meses pero
no solo eso la reforma también perseguía
darle a la marina británica el control
de las aguas territoriales del Canal y
encargarse de controlar la inmigración
por esta vía pero es que además se
incluyó esta otra posibilidad si van por
ese camino si cruzan el Canal de la
Mancha ilegalmente en esos botes se
arriesgan a terminar no en el Reino
Unido sino en Ruanda habéis oído bien
para combatir la inmigración ilegal el
gobierno demolición son alcanzó un
acuerdo con Ruanda en África para que
este país recibiera a todos aquellos
inmigrantes que no fueran por el Reino
Unido
básicamente las autoridades británicas
derivarían al país africano a todas
aquellas personas con solicitudes
rechazadas que no fueran consideradas
aptas o que estuvieran viviendo en el
país de forma ilegal Pues bien el primer
vuelo bajo este nuevo plan de
deportaciones masivas estaba programado
para el día 14 de junio del año 2022
pero tuvo que ser suspendido por una
medida cautelar del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos y diréis por qué Pues
porque la idea británica parecía chocar
con múltiples convenciones
internacionales además existen serias
dudas de que sea la mejor opción el
historial de Ruanda en la cajita de
deportados suscita inquietud ante el
esquema del Reino Unido de unas 4.000
personas que se estima Fueron deportadas
por Israel a Ruanda y uganda bajo un
esquema de salida voluntaria entre 2014
y 2017 se cree que casi todas
abandonaron el país casi de inmediato y
muchas intentaron regresar a Europa por
su parte la experiencia de Australia que
durante años ha hecho con los
inmigrantes ilegales algo muy parecido
también ha despertado muchas críticas y
muchas muchísimas dudas los refugiados
de nauru La Isla donde los niños
Perdieron el deseo de vivir hemos
comenzado a ver conductas suicidas en
niños de tan solo 8 y 10 años dice Lucy
Newman profesora de psiquiatría de la
Universidad de Melbourne Australia que
trabaja con familias y niños en la isla
El caso es que la crisis de gobierno de
Boris Johnson primero y la detrás
después pararon la alternativa de Ruanda
y pese a ello y pese a todas las
críticas podemos decir que Johnson tenía
una posición razonablemente aperturista
al menos si la comparamos con la
situación actual porque sí Ahora hay un
nuevo gobierno y sabéis que el equipo de
Richie sunat se ha sumergido en una
enorme batalla parlamentaria para sacar
adelante su propia reforma de la misma
ley que ya fue modificada hace poco más
de un año a instancias del gobierno de
Boris Johnson Y eso que son del mismo
partido
[Música]
pero lo más curioso es que pese a que
los británicos no tienen ningún problema
con la llegada de inmigrantes y
refugiados el gobierno de sunak quiere
endurecer la ley de Johnson habéis oído
bien por ejemplo la ley de Boris Johnson
permitía que los refugiados que
ingresaran y regularmente en el país
pudieran optar a un permiso de
permanencia de 30 meses Pues bien Ahora
el objetivo del gobierno de sunak es
impedir que cualquier persona que entre
de forma irregular pueda conseguir
ningún permiso ni estatus de residencia
ni siquiera el de refugiado la idea es
una es que si entras irregularmente en
el país Ni tú ni tampoco tus hijos
podréis lograr ningún tipo de permiso de
residencia el espíritu es que si entras
irregularmente sea cual sea tu situación
te enfrentarás Sí o sí a la detención y
a la deportación el proyecto de ley
modificará radicalmente la forma de
tratar a las personas que llegan
ilegalmente al Reino Unido a través de
países seguros haciendo inadmisibles su
solicitudes de asilo y de protección de
los Derechos Humanos respecto a su país
de origen e imponiendo al ministro del
interior la obligación de expulsarlas y
ojo porque esto supone cargarse de facto
la figura del asilo político Reino Unido
ya no sería un destino posible para
aquellas personas que se vean obligadas
a marcharse lo antes posibles de sus
países por el que están siendo
perseguidos vale que hay mucho fraude en
estos casos de refugiados pero
evidentemente muchas situaciones si tu
vida o tu libertad corren un peligro
inminente por ejemplo por defender unas
ideas políticas o la democracia no te
vas a poner a realizar trámites
burocráticos que te pueden llevar años
Pues bien el plan de sunat no tendría
nada de esto en cuenta Esta es una de
las principales críticas a una apuesta
política que como veis es muy estricta
mucho más que la apuesta de Boris
Johnson pero ojo porque esto no es todo
justo aquí es cuando se pone la cosa
particularmente cruda
[Aplausos]
porque ahora el gobierno de sunat ha
redoblado su apuesta y ya oficializado
el acuerdo con Ruanda Pese a que según
las encuestas la mayoría de los
británicos Están en contra del mismo el
objetivo de este acuerdo es crear un
mecanismo para la reubicación de los
solicitantes de asilo cuya solicitud es
no estén siendo estudiadas por el Reino
Unido en Ruanda que tramitará su
solicitudes y asentará o expulsará Según
proceda a las personas Una vez que se
decida sobre su solicitud y la pregunta
la gran pregunta es si en principio los
británicos ya no tienen tantos problemas
con la inmigración y sí están en contra
de deportar a la gente a Ruanda Por qué
este empeño político Pues básicamente
por esto elecciones locales 2023 los
laboristas superan a los conservadores
como partido mayoritario en el gobierno
local la pandemia la caída de Boris
Johnson la crisis tras la inflación la
subida de tipos el estado de la economía
el partido conservador se está
enfrentando a una durísima crisis
electoral
[Música]
tal y como podéis ver en este gráfico
las encuestas son muy claras de cara
muchísimas lecciones de 2025 hoy por hoy
los laboristas parecen los claros
favoritos y la pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo todos es pero y que pintan todo
esto la inmigración Pues básicamente que
todo apunta a que el gobierno de sunak
quiere volver a convertirla en una de
sus grandes caballos de batalla es decir
que el gobierno podría querer volver a
poner esta cuestión en el candelero para
demostrar un poco de mano dura y de
fuerza es algo que a los conservadores
les funcionó en el pasado y por eso
Ahora parece que quieren volver a
intentarlo y precisamente por eso están
lanzando mensajes e iniciativas
particularmente duras como recluir a los
inmigrantes ilegales en un enorme marco
Gran Bretaña comienza a recluir a
emigrantes en una embarcación calificada
de trampa mortal por los bomberos o
hacer anuncios como este
[Música]
qué queréis que os diga convertir en una
especie de espectáculo y anuncios
publicitarios Pues a mí no me parece que
sea la mejor forma de tratar este
problema Por supuesto Esto se está
haciendo esencialmente con los
refugiados y con los inmigrantes
ilegales porque a la hora de la verdad
lo más probable es que Reino Unido siga
emitiendo tantos permisos de trabajo
como viene haciendo hasta ahora al fin y
al cabo si algo está claro es que la
economía británica va a seguir
necesitando mucha mano de obra nueva en
otras palabras que más allá de lo
importante que resulte desincentivar la
inmigración ilegal o si de hay cosas que
mejorar O no en el sistema migratorio
británico hay muchas sospechas de que
los últimos cambios legales podrían
responder simplemente a un criterio
fundamentalmente electoral con todos los
problemas que tiene Reino Unido esto qué
quieres que os diga no me parece una
prioridad sensata pero sea como sea
llegado desde punto turno para vosotros
qué os parece la apuesta política de
suna estáis de acuerdo con las
deportaciones a Ruanda qué os parecen
este tipo de iniciativas contra la
inmigración puedes dejarnos vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribís este
canal y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]